[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلها بابره
العنود
[تصفيق]
بعد حل شرطه الاخلاق الرئيس الايرانيه
يشير الى امكانيه دراسه مواد بدستور
البلاد
اجتماع كان الهدف بالوضع السياسي الراهن
والتشاور حول كيفيه الوحده الصف الوطني
الاسود الثلاثه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
بينما كان النظام الايراني يتوقعوا تراجعا
بوطيره الاحتجاجات بعد حل ما تسمى بشرطه
الاخلاق وامكانيه دراسه اعاده النظر ببنود
الدستور اطلقت بيانات عكس التيار تدعو الى
مزيد من الاحتجاجات واطاله مده الاضطرابات
من ساعات والاضرابات من ساعات الى ايام
بدء من يوم غد الخامس من ديسمبر الى
السابع منه بينما حذرت منظمه العفو
الدوليه من خطر اعدام ثمانيه وعشرين من
المحتاجين المعتقلين بينهم ثلاثه اطفال
صياما بعد نقلهم الى غرف انفراديه وسجون
اخرى دون الكشف عن مصيرهم او محاكمتهم
وشديده على ان طهران تستخدم عقوبه الاعدام
للقمع السياسي وارهابي
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
اذا شرطه الاخلاق اولى اضحات الاحتجاجات
في ايران وربما لاحقا بنود من الدستور
ايضا ايطاحه اعتبرها محتجون الهديه الاولى
لمهحه امين الشاب الكرديه التي اشعلت فتيل
المظاهرات فيما يرى البعض ان هذه الخطوه
تمثل الحد الادنى من مطالب المتظاهرين ففي
محاوله لاحتواء موجه الغضب التي يشهدها
الشارع الايراني منذ اكثر من شهرين ونصف
اعلن المدعي العام الايراني محمد جعفر
منتظري حل ما تسمى بشرطه الاخلاق المتطو-
المتورطه بمقتل مهسه معتبر بدايه تنازلات
النظام الايراني تحسبا لتفادي الاسود شملت
ايضا مراجعه البرلمان والسلطه القضائيه
للقانون الذي يفرض على النساء ويف عليهن
وضع غطاء للراس ودراسه امكانيه الغاء
الزاميه الحجاب الذي يعود قراره الى العام
1983 وكانت شرطه الاخلاق واسمها بالفارسيه
جست ارشاد اي دوريات الارشاد قد تاسست سنه
2007 ويحق لعناصر هذه الشرطه توجيه
الاتهامات وفرض غرامات او حتى اعتقال من
تعتقد انهن يخالفن القواعد وهو ما فتح
الباب لممارسه الانتهاكات بحق نساء ايران
واخرها بحق سامي الامر الذي دفع ببعض
الدول الغربيه بينها الولايات المتحده الى
فرض عقوبات على شرطه الاخلاق الايرانيه
لكن فيما يبدو ان تنازلات النظام الايراني
لن تتوقف عند نقاط الحجاب اذ اعلن الرئيس
الايراني انه من الممكن اعاده النظر ايضا
في مواد بالدستور الايراني
لم تذهب هتافاتهم سدا المحتجون في ايران
حقق انتصارا نوعيا وذلك بعد قرابه اربعه
اشهر من التظاهرات المستمره شرطه الاخلاق
ليس لها علاقه بالقضاء والغاها من انشاها
اعلان هو التراجع الاول من النظام
للمحتجين الذين ورغم مقتل المئات منهم
حافظوا على زخم الاحتجاجات وتوسعها من
محافظه اخرى المدعي العام الايراني المح
ايضا الى ان البرلمان والسلطه القضائيه
يعملان على مراجعه قانون الحجاب متوقعا ان
تظهر نتائج هذه المراجعه خلال اسبوعين على
الاكثر
النظام المحب دوره الى مزيد من التنازلات
في محاوله الاحتواء غضب الشارع
تنازلات قد تصل الى حد ادخال تعديلات على
الدستورنا له مواد ثابته وغير قابله تغيير
جمهوريه النظام واسلامته ومبدا الاستقلال
والحريه والحقوق والحريات التي يصرح بها
الدستور اساليب واليات لتطبيق القانون
ولكن يمكن دراستها
تصريحات حاره الشارع الغاضب في تفسيرها
بين من اعتبرها اذعانا للضغوط الداخليه
والخارجيه ومن عدها تكتيكا مؤقتا يهدف
لمنح قوى الامن وقتا كافيا للقضاء على
التظاهرات
بل ان تلميح رئيس بامكانيه تعديل الدستور
قد لا يجدوا طريقه للتنفيذ في الواقع
لاسباب مختلفه
فالدستور الايراني يمنح المرشد الاعلى
صلاحيات مطلقه تمكنه من الغاء اي قرار في
البلاد والمرشد الاعلى علي الخامنائي يعد
القائد الاعلى للقوات الايرانيه اي انه
يتفرد بالقوه المطلقه
ورغم هذا يحتفل محتاجون بقرار الغاء شرطه
الاخلاق واعاده النظر في قانون الحجاب
فالقرارات ولو كانت شكليه الا انها تعني
ان النظام مستعد لتقديم المزيد في حال
استمرار التظاهرات
بدوره يجدد وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد اللهيان اتهام بلاده واشنطن بدعم
الاحتجاجات الاخيره في اعلان من اجل الضغط
على طهران للامتسال لمطالبها المتعلقه
بالمفاوضات النوويه وقال وزير الخارجيه
الايراني ان الدول الغربيه تستغل الاحداث
الاخيره في بلاده وان الولايات المتحده
تشجع اعمال العنف في
من دبي بالسيديو ينضم الينا الباحث في
الشان الايراني مسعود الفك اهلا بك
هذا الاجراء التخديري
الاحتيال نوعا ما على المتظاهرين بما ان
معظم الاهيئات مثل النهايات النهي عن
المنكر وايضا البسيج وغير مازالت قائمه
وبالتالي نحن لا نتحدث عن اجراءات غيريه
حقيقيه هل ستنطلي على المتظاهرين
بلا شك هذا الاجراء في واقع الامر هو
محاوله لاختزال همم المطالب واختجال همم
التراكم همم لمده اربعه عقود ونيف من
المقالب التي لم تتحقق حتى المطالب التي
يحترف بها الدستور الايرانيات مثل التشكيل
الاحزاب مثل حتى تعليم لغه
الام للقوميات المختلفه في ايران هذه وجود
هذه المواد في الدستور الايراني الان
يحاولون اختزالها بمساله الحجاب المساله
تجاوزت الحجاب كنا
نتحدى بقى ان بفلسفه النظام وفلسفه المرشد
التنازلات لا توجد يعني غير موجوده
بالقاموس لانها ممكن ان تجر لتنازلات اخرى
لماذا تنازلوا ولو حتى شكلي»
انا اعتبر هو اعتراف بالامر الواقع لانه
الان في الشارع الايراني بضغط المحتجين
بات مساله الحجاب مراعاته بالطريقه التي
تريدها الحكومه او بالطريقه التي يتم
اتباعها من قبل همم النساء او الخروج الى
الشارع بدون حجاب اصبح امرا واقع في
الشارع لذا اعتبر هذا الامر هو اعتراض بما
يحدث في الشارع وخارج السلطه
امر واقع شديد هذا هو الامر لذا احت-
استمرار الاحتجاجات وديهمتها وهناك غدا
هناك دعوه للاحتجاجات قد وتستمر لثلاثه
ايام هذه السلسله المتواصله من الاحتجاجات
قد ترغم النظام على تنازلات حقيقيه وليست
تنازلات شكليه بالشق الاخر هناك ضغط على
النظام من الخارج ايضا اوروبا بريطانيا
امريكا كندا كلها فرضت عقوبات على ما يعرف
بالشرطه الاخلاق وبالتالي التخلص منها
اصبحت اعلى النظام هل ايضا من خلفيات هذا
القرار هو التخفيف الضغط الخارجي
الضغط الخارجي باعتقاده يبقى ضغط همم رمزي
وضغط اخلاقي قد يطعم المحتجين ويعطيهم
نفسيه للاستمراريه الا انه لن يغير من
موقف النظام الايراني النظام الايراني
باعتقادي اذا لم تكن هناك
اجراءات سياسيه واجراءات اقتصاديه
لن يتراجع عن موقفه الاجراءات السياسيه قد
تتمثل في سحب السفراء او طرد السفراء
الايرانيين من هذه البلدان والاجراءات
الاقتصاديه تتمثل في عقوبات اقتصاديه لا
تتعلق فقط بالملف النووي بل تتعلق بمن
قضايا حقوق الانسان داخليه
على النظام بالموضوع يعني هناك اي مطالب
حقوقيه داخليه هناك مطالب اجتماعيه ايضا
اجتمعت كلها
وانتجت هذه المظاهرات وهذه الثوره التي
شاهدناها اليوم في ايران هناك همم واحد من
اربعه مواطنين يعيش تحت خط الفقر وبالتالي
تجاهل ما يريد الشعب الايراني اصبح صعب ما
المتوقع من هذه التظاهرات بالمرحله
المقبله بالمرحله المقبله انا اتوقع لو
استطاع النظام ان يخمد الاحتجاجات
الاجتماعيه والاحتجاجات الشعبيه سوف يواجه
نوع جديد من الاحتجاجات وتتوسع هذه
الاحتجاجات تتمثل في خروج العمال المعلمين
همم اصحاب المهن همم همم
الكوادر الطبيه في ايران هذه الاحتجاجات
ستكون في المرحله المقبله لماذا لان مساله
الذي تفضلت واشارتي اليه مساله خطر مساله
الغلاف مساله الوضع المعيشي الصعب سيكون
المحرك الاساسي لاي احتجاج مستقبلي حتى لو
كانت الاحتجاجات غير مرتبطه بالقضايا
السياسيه وبالتالي كل يعني الافكار
الجيولوجيه ستنهز معها ايضا شكرا لك يا
استاذ مسعود الفك البحث في الشان الايراني
حدثنا بالاستوديو مباشر شكرا
[موسيقى]
بينما يترقب السودانيون توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي بين عدد من الاحزاب والحركات
المسلحه التي يشغل قضتها مناصب في الدوله
نفت قوى الحريه والتغيير الاخبار التي
تتحدث عن تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق المقرر غدا
الاثنين واكدت ان المبادئ العامه وبنود
الاتفاق الايطالي واضحه بشان اهداف الثوره
وتحقيق الانتقال الديمقراطي وانها مستمره
في سعرها لتوحيد الجبهه المدنيه الساعيه
لانهاء الازمه وتحقيق السلام العادل
والشامل والمستدام بالاضافه الى تاسيس وضع
دستوري جديد يلبي مطالب الحركه الجماهيريه
وصولا طبعا الى اتفاق النهائي الذي يمهد
عمليا لفتره الانتقاليه
[موسيقى]
وفي مؤتمر صحفي قرر الحزب الاتحادي
الديمقراطي الاصل تجميد عضويه رئيس الحزب
محمد الحسن الميرنجي بسبب ما وصفه الحزب
بخروجه عن خط او الميرغني اييي الخروج عن
خط الحزب بموافقته على الاتفاق الايطالي
معتبرا ان توقيعه على اي ورقه لا يلزم
الحزب في اي شيء قرروا التجميد بحقه ياتي
قبل ساعات على موعد توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي الذي سيوقع حضور دولي واقلمه في
القصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم وافقت على
توقيعه احزاب سياسيه من خارج الحريه
والتغيير لكنها تدعم عمليه التحول
نظام مدني ديموقراطيه فيما رفضته احزاب
الامه القوميه والتجمع الاتحادي والمؤتمر
السوداني والحركه الشعبيه التيار الثوري
الديمقراطي والاتحاد الديمقراطي وحسب
المؤتمر الشعبي كما ترفض الاتفاق الاحزاب
المنضويه تحت مبادره نداء اهل السودان
وعلى راسها الحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه
والمجلس الاعلى للنظارات البيجو
والعموديات المستقله ودعي بعض هؤلاء الى
تشكيل جبهه معارضه في هذا الاتفاق
احكم عليها بالفشل لانه ذات المشكله اللي
كانت موجوده في خمسه اشهر طبعا هتتكرر
ممكن نسحب في اي يوم نصحى الصباح نجيء
لانه نفس البيان بتاع 25 اكتوبر تكرر ثاني
وثالث ورابط لانه وهم موجودين على قياده
ال- اا الجيش وعلى قياده الدعم السريع
افتكري انه فرصناحه الشارع باكد انه ما
هتكون فيها فرص نجاح يعني افتكر انه
التسويه تاسس له الحكومه مدني نسبه
التجارب الكثيره اللي حصلت يعني ما بين
المدنيين والعسكريين ما نجحنا لانه لا انت
ما بتقرب المدرب
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا ابو بكر عمر بامين
الاتصال التنظيمي في حزب الاتحاد
الديمقراطي استاذ ابو بكر انتم اليوم
تقولون بان هذا الاتفاق لا يؤدي الى
الاستقرار المطلوب والانتقال المطلوب
بالعمليه السياسيه السودانيه لماذا ولماذا
هذا الرفد لهذا الاتفاق
مساء الخير استاذتي مرحبا بالمشاهدين
والسلام عليكم في البلد علق على التقرير
الرفع في الاول هو تجميد لسيد الحسن
المرغني عضو المكتب السياسي وهو ليس هناء
وليس الحزب وليس رئيس الحزب كما ذكرتهم
وهو عضو المكتب السياسي همم نائب رئيس
الحزب هو جعفر رئيس الحزب الاتحاد الاصلي
همم اما جاء بخصوص السؤال همم الاتفاق
يعني همم اولا عنده مشكله بتاعه همم انه
يتدفع نهائيا في السودان على ثلاثه مرات
وفي الثلاث مرات
الداعي لانه همم يكون العمليه السياسيه مش
يكون فيها اكبر قدر ممكن من ال- همم من
اللي قال المقاومه من الاحزاب السياسيه
والحركات المسلحه كلها عشان ما تدعم
الفتره الانتقاليه وتدعم التحول
الديمقراطي المشاركه الحكم دائما وابدا
بتكون في صالح المدنيين في صالحه
بسنت يكون في همم جهتين بيعملوا اتفاقات
تكون هي
وليس لها اي قواعد على الارض ومرفوضه
بشعبيا وسياسيا بمغامره
بتقود الطرفين للاحتراق وبتقود البلد كمان
لمحرق الكبير جدا ممكن يدفع ثمن
السودانيين
والدول الدول الجوار وكمان
فبهذا الصدد المساله بتاعه اتفاقات ثنائيه
مرفوضه بالكامل ده الحاجه الاولى
الاملاءات الاجنبيه التي فرضت على على
المكونين المدني والعسكري والذات الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي والمقاومه
العسكري يظهر لنا ان كان الضغوطات اكبر
مما يتحمله
وموضو فيها همم الانبات الخارجيه ما حد
يقف مسالته انه تم التسويه لانه نفس
الجهاز يحط واصل عملها هتواصل تدخلات بعد
احتمال التسويه بعد التحويل الديمقراطيه
ربما بعد الانتخابات
بعض المعترضين بان هذا الاتفاق يحمل همم
حسنات جنائيه جنائيه وصفقات سريه وانه
اسوا مرحله في سلب اراده واداره البلاد
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني لماذا لماذا كل هذه
السلبيه بهذا الاتصال
الى الان طبعا هو اتفاق سري بالكامل يعني
ويعجز كل الموجودين الان على انه يخرجوا
نسخه منه
حتى المكون العسكري والحريه والتغيير يعني
همم محتفظين بالنسخ لنفسهم وهو بيقول احنا
بندعي لجميع لانه يخرج في العمليه
السياسيه هم عندهم اتفاق اصلا همم اجروه
وفيه وفيه هو همم فيه حاجات ترابيزه وتحت
الترابيزه معروف شكله كيف همم من الصعب
ممكن من المستحيل انك تستدعي جهات سياسيه
لتوقع على شيء لم تعرفه ولم تناقش لم لم
تدرك تفاصيلها لم تعرف اليها فما من
المنطق في شيء انه الناس تخوض في تجربه
همم عارفه نتائج مسوقها وتجربه مجهوله همم
العقود همم الاتفاق نفسه مجهول بالنسبه
لهم المحصل النهايه بتاعته معروفين انها
محصله سلبيه همم انجيلا بعد عسكريه او
التدخلات خارجيه وفي الاخر يعني هندخل في
الدوامه بتاعه 30 يونيو
و25 اكتوبر وثلاثه وثلاثه يونيو هخش في
تجارب نفسها تعالي وتتكرر وبعدين الرئيس
يعني لا نقول اننا العود اليه
في الحته دي واقول انه الشارع ما في حزب
سياسي بيقدر يقول انا هارجع الشارع او انا
هافوت الشارع الفعل الثوري عمل مستمر وعمل
يعني مجلس السودانيين يعني حاجه بتاعه
احزاب عشان ما تقول ان احنا بنحرك الشارع
او كده لا دعم سوري ممكن على حسابك كوادر
لمظاهره بين اثنين لكن العمل الفعلي
الثوري المستمر على العمل
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الاوضاع السيئه تشعل الفتيل الاحتجاجات في
السويداء والنظام السوري يواجهها بالرصاص
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات غاضبه لاهل السويداء تعود بقوه
وتواجهها قوات الامن السوري بالرصاص وتقتل
متظاهر في واقعه هي الاولى منذ سنوات
المرصده السوري قال ان مئات المواطنين في
المدينه احتجوا على تدهور الاوضاع
المعيشيه وعدم تامين المستلزمات
والمستلزمات الحياه الضروريه في المدينه
وتمكنوا من اقتحام مبنى المحافظه جانب
ازاله صوره بشار الاسد المعلقه في واجهه
المبنى ما ادى لهرب الموظفين من المبدا في
ظل توتر امني شديد في المدينه واحياء هذه
المدينه فيما اطلقت قوات النظام الرصاص
تجاه المتظاهرين امام مبنى المحافظه ومبنى
قياده الشرطه وسط المدينه ما اسفل ذلك عن
وقوع قتيل عدد من الاصابات في صفوفهم اما
اعلام النظام السوري فوصف المحتجين في
السويداء في جنوب الشرقيه من سوريا بانهم
مجموعه ان الهاربين من العداله وقال انهم
احرقوا وثائق رسميه ونشرت شبكات محليه
سوريه صورا وتسجيلات مصوره لمحتاجين اثناء
التدمير سياره امنيه كما نشاهد هنا محمله
برشاش بعد دخولها في صفوفهم اضافه لاحراق
عربه مصفحه تابعه للنظام في محيط مبنى
السرايا الحكوميه تعبيرا طبعا عن الغضب
الشعبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من تورنتو ينضم الينا الدكتور هشام مروه
عضو الائتلاف الوطني السوري او هشام مروه
عضو الائتلاف الوطني السوري استاذ هشام
يعني ما يحصل من احتقان في هذه في هذه
المحافظه خصوصا انها منذ الثوره السوريه
في العام 2011 وهي لم تهدا اليوم هل تقاعس
النظام بسبب ازمته الداخليه ام انها
متعمده
مساء الخير لكل مشاهدين في الحقيقه تحيه
للشعب السوري جميعا الذي يتحمل اسد الظروف
في هذه المرحله
الفساد والاستبداد الذي لازال النظام
يمارسوا من حوالي 12 سنه ما يجري في
السويداء الحقيقه مؤهل ان يكون في اي مكان
في سوريا
الفساد الذي يقوم به النظام من الان اصبح
السرقه يعني فوت الناس
والفساد الذي وجدت في سوريا لم يقتل الناس
الان الحد الادنى من الحياه لو وضعنا
الاقتصاديه لا يمكن ان تختمر ولذلك كان
لابد من استمرار بسبب باستمرار باستمرار
الاستبداد ان يكون هذا الاتجاه سواء او في
غيرها فلذلك الامر لا هو بسبب السياسي
المستمر والتي يسر عليها النظام في هذه
الاونه التي بدات من عامل 21
سوريا ولكن همم ما جرى في سوريا من 11 سنه
الى الان لازال يعالج منه
يتحدثون عن اجراءات عقابيه من قبل النظام
لهم بسبب مواقفهم المعارضه منذ ان بدات
الثوره وحتى اليوم هل هذا الموضوع يعني
فيه خلفيه
لموقف الاخوه في همم السويد ده وفي محافظه
وفي كل المحافظات في سوريا
ما معنى ارسال التعزيزات العسكريه ما معنى
همم اطلاق النار الحي على المتباينه هذا
الامر او باخر انه نعم هي اجراءات عقبيه
نعم امام الانهيار التام هناك تحديد شلل
بالمحافظه وهناك ازمه ثقه بين الناس من
جهه وبين المواطنين طبعا وبين النظام ما
الحل
الحل بالنسبه
لسوريا ده كله
وهي ان يتراجع النظام عن اسلوب الحل
الامني والحل العسكري الذي يمارسه في حل
القضا
يا واتجاه الحل السياسي الذي فرضته الامم
المتحده وطالبات الامم المتحده لقرار هذه
54 اذا نظام الصر على الحل الامني والحل
السياسي حتى الان في موضوع السويداء
الموضوع اكثر وربما يمتد الى الساحل يمتد
الى مناطق اخرى في سوريا الوضع اصبح في
سوريا
والحل الامني الذي يعمل عليه النظام من
ضغط مواجهته في انخفاضات الشعب السوري
2011 تفضل شكرا لك يا دكتور هشام مروه
حدثتنا من تورته عضو الاختلاف الوطني
السوري
في سوريا ايضا لكن الى الجزء الشمالي منها
اذ هو تحت عنوان الاكراد الحليف الاكثر
ولا ان لامريكا فلا تنسونا نشهدا مظلوم
عبادي القائد العام لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه واشنطن وطالبها بعدم التخلي
عن الاكراد في سوريا والمقاتلين هناك عبر
منع العمليه العسكريه التي تنوي تركيا
شنها ضد الاكراد شمال وشرقي سوريا واضاف
انه لا توجد كراهيه متاصله بين الاكراد
والاكراد ولكن القاده الاتراك اتخذوا
خيارا سياسيا بمعامله الكرد على انهم
تهديد امنيه لهم وهذه خطوه خاطئه وفقا
لقائد قصد
[موسيقى]
بدا الجيش العراقي بنشري وحدات من قوات
حرس الحدود على طول الحدود مع كل من ايران
وتركيا وذلك بعد سلسله من القصف التركي
والايراني على اقليم كردستان العراق واكد
الناطق باسم القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
العراقيه اللواء يحيى يحيى الرسول ان
اجراءات ضبط الحدود بدات بالفعل مع تعزيز
قوه حرس الحدود والمخافر الحدوديه
بالاسلحه والمعدات والافراد لضمان القيام
بمهماتها بشكل جيد مشددا على ان هذه
القوات ستتواجد على حدود اقليم كردستان
العراق مع ايران وتركيا مضيفا بالوقت
ذاتها ان العراق يرفض استخدام اراضيه
لتهديد دول الشوار
وجه السيد القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
بتعزيز قوات الحدود بالاشخاص والمعدات
من الاراضي العراق
معنا من الدهون كفاح محمود المستشار
السابق لرئيس اقليم كردستان العراق استاذ
محمود يعني هذا القرار الذي يمثل نوع من
التهدئه مع ايران وتركيا السؤال الاساسي
فيه هو ديمومه هذا القرار يعني بالاشهر
المقبله سابدا من الموضوع التركي اذا كان
الجانب التركي يعتبر ان على الاقليم وعلى
العراق ان يخوض حرب ضد المسلحين الاكراد
وان يجردهم من كل شيء هل ممكن ان يدوم
يعني قرار عدم قصفهم وضربهم بالاشهر
المقبله
بدايه السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
بالتاكيد ال لا الاقليم ولا بغداد يعني
بودها ان تنتهي الامور
بتداخل عسكري بمعنى
بمقاتله الفئات في الاصل هي في اسياسيه
لجات من تركيا او من ايران لجات الى
العراق ليس اليوم منذ سبعينيات وثمانينيات
القرن الماضي والسلطنه في في عده مخيمات
مخيمات اللاجئين الكردي القادمين من تركيا
والقادمين من ايران
اعتقد تفعيل قوات حرس الحدود وتجهيزها
بالاسلحه الحديثه
وفي زياده عددها وزياده عدد مخاطرها همم
ربما سيعمل على تقليص هذا الاختراق الذي
يحصل سواء من الحدود التركيه مع اقليم
كردستان او الحدود الايرانيه مع اقليم
كردستان لكن ان يصل الى حد الاحترام مع
هذه القوه انا شخصيا استبعده لانه اولا
المناطق التي وجد فيها المسلحين وانت
سالتيني عن الجانب التركي منطقه همم وعره
جدا لا يمكن لا للجيش العراقي ولا لجيش
التركي التواجد فيها لانها مجموعه من
الكهوف في منطقه واعره جدا همم
ممكن ان تخف ولكن ممكن ان تعاود تركيا
استناف بالموضوع الايراني الموضوع
الايراني وقذف الحدود لا يتعلق بالتهريب
وبكل ما يعني ابداعته ايران بالاون
الاخيره انما يتعلق بالتظاهرات والتظاهرات
ما زالت مستمره ويعني همم وبالتالي
الذريعه ما زالت موجوده هل ممكن ايضا ان
يستانف النظام الايراني ضرباته
يعني كما قلت اكثر من مره من على شاشه
تكون هنا ان الموضوع سياسي اكثر مما هو
يعني كما تدعي وسائل الاعلام
تهريب اسلحه او او دعم او تحفيز الى اخره
انا اعتقد الايرانيين يعني يرسلون او او
يهربون الى الامام بنقل الازماتهم الى
خارج خارج ايران هناك ضغط شعبي كبير على
الاداره السياسيه في ايران انا اعتقد
اليوم مثلا
بالغائهم قانون شرطه الاخلاق بالغائهم
شرطه الاخلاق وثم تعديل قوانين الحجاب
والتجمد اعتقد هذه بدايه يعني ربما ستساهم
في في في تهدئه الاجواء بدلا من استخدام
عمليه همم تازيم الوضع مع العراق في اقليم
كردستان او مع غير العراق انا اعتقد
العمليات القصف كما قلت لك كانت سياسيه
اكثر من ما هي همم سعر على على الواقع في
الارض لانه عمليه عمليات التهريب
تفضلت عمليات التهريب بين الدول لا يمكن
السيطره عليها وقد ذكرت اكثر من ذلك همم
في كثير من دول العالم شكرا لك استاذ كفاح
محمود المستشار السابق لرئيس اقليم
كردستان العراق على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
في الحرب الاوكرانيه قالت نشلت بوليسيكو
الامريكيه ان تقديرا لمايكروسوفت حذر من
ان الحكومه الروسيه تنسق الهجمات
الالكترونيه على البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه بضربات صاروخيه متزامنه مع
انسحاب قواتها من مناطق في اوكرانيا
التقرير اشار الى ان الكريم لن يسعى الى
توسيع الهجمات الالكترونيه ضد جيران
اوكرانيا الداعمين لها في محاوله لتعطيل
سلاسل التوريد العسكريه والانسانيه واضعاف
دعم الاوروبيين لكاف وذكر تقرير
مايكروسوفت ان اختراق روسيا لانظمه
الاقمار الصناعيه الاوكرانيه وشركات
الطاقه وغيرها من البنيه التحتيه اثار
مخاوف دوليه حول كيفيه نشر موسكو لقدراتها
السبرانيه المتطوره بعد ذلك
تحذيرات الغربيه متزامنه مع اعتقادات
دوليه بان سيناريو الحرب الالكترونيه
الشامله باتا واقعيه
من جهته اكد المستشار الالماني اوليف شولد
بان بلاده ستواصل والحلفاء تزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه التي تحتاجها حتى يوقف بوتين
الحرب ويسحب قوته من الاراضي الاكرانيه
بالاسلحه التي تحتاجها لصد هجمات روسيا
حتى يوقف بوتين هذه الحرب ويسحب قواته ان
تنتهي هذه الحرب والعدوانيه في وقت قريب
لا نعرف متى لكنها ستنتهي وهناك شيء واضح
ستفشل مهم ثبوت الروسيه وهي قد فشلت
بالفعل
الكلب اللغم اسلوب حربي جديد ربما تستخدمه
روسيا في الحرب في اوكرانيا في مشهد يعيد
للاذهان ما حصل في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بين السوفيات والالماظ وفي التفاصيل
مشاهدينا اقترح فيكتور ماكاروف قيادي في
الحزب الشيوعي في روسيا على جيش بلاده
استخدام الحيوانات التي لاموا لها خصوصا
الكلاب المشرده كمفجرين انتحاريين في
الحرب ضد القوات الاكرانيه والطريقه التي
سيتم فيها زوج هذه الكلاب في الحرب هي
اولا جمعت تلك الحيوانات المشرده داخل
معسكرات للجيش وتدريبها على حمل المنفخات
والمواد المتفجره والرط بها لمسافات طويله
حتى الوصول للهدف اما الهدف الرئيس لتلك
الكلاب الملاغمه او المنفخه هو دبابات
ومدافع الجيش الاوكراني ما نتابع هنا حيث
تحمل تلك الكلاب استشعارات وبمجرد ان يلمس
الكلب الدبابه او المدفع تنفجر المفخخات
بحاملها وهذا بالتحديد ما استخدمه الجيش
السوفياتي ضد القوات الالمانيه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وكانت وسيله ومحاوله
زحف الالمان نحو اراضهم وكان الطريق انذاك
بتشويع الكلاب ووضع الطعام لها تحت
الدبابات وبالتالي ترويضها على ان المكان
الاول للبحث عن الطعام هو اسفل الدبابات
ثم تحميلها باثنين 10 كلغ من المتفجرات
واطلاقها نحو دبابات الجيش الالماني وعن
نتائجها وفعليتها انساك تقول التقارير
السوفياتيه ان هذه الكلاب استطاعت تدمير
300 دبابه المانيه وسببت مشاكل كبيره داخل
الجيش الالماني وهنا اجبر الجيش الالماني
على اللجوء لاص اوامر باطلاق النار على
الكلاب فور رؤيتها وحرقها بقاذفات اللهب
قبل ان تقترب بالنقاط او معدات او اسلحه
للقوات الالمانيه
[موسيقى]
بما يسمى باسطول الظل تسعى روسيا لتخفيف
العقوبات النفطيه الغربيه
ناقله قديمه لنقل النفط الخام صحيفه
البريطانيه كشفت عن ان بعض التجار
هذا سيقلل من تاثير الاجراءات الاوروبيه
صياما بعد تحديد سقف جديد لسعر النفط
لواقع 60 دولارا للبراميل هؤلاء التجار
وفقا الصحيفه البريطانيه يرون ان روسيا
تهدف الى استخدام اسطولها الجديد في
محاوله امداد دول الهند والصين وتركيا
التي اصبحت اكبر مشتريها مع تراجع السوق
الاوروبي وبالتالي التحايل على العقوبات
الغربيه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه لا تستبعد تكرار
التصعيد في قطاع غزه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد توقعت مصادر عسكريه
اسرائيليه بان يتكرر التصعيد الذي شهده
قطاع غزه فجر اليوم في كل مره تشهد فيها
الضفه الغربيه تصعيدا ميدانيا جديا على
الرغم من عدم رغبه حماس والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في خوض حرب في هذا التوقيت
وكانت اسرائيل شنته سلسله غارات في اعقاب
سقوط صاروخ فلسطينيه في محيط مستوطنه
نحن هنا على حدود قطاع غزه حيث يسود هدوء
حبر لكنه يبدو هشا قابل للانكسار في اي
لحظه بعد التصعيد الخطير وهو الاخطر عمليا
منذ اربعه اشهر منذ الحمله العسكريه
الاسرائيليه الاخيره على قطاع غزه مرد هذا
التصعيد تقول اسرائيل انه التصعيد الحاصل
دراماتيكيا في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله وهنا اسرائيل باتت عالقه في
معادله تحاول الافلات منها وهي ان اي جبهه
تنفجر يمكن لها ان تفجر الجبهات الاخرى ان
كان في القدس او الطفل الغربيه المحتله او
هنا في قطاع غزه وعلى الارض تبقي اسرائيل
حالته بالقسوه من خلال نشر المزيد من
بطاريات القبه الحديديه على حدود قطاع غزه
وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه وسط خشيه لدى
المؤسسه الامنيه في اسرائيل من ان الحكومه
المغتربه ووجود المتطرف بين كبير فيها
وزيرا للامن الداخليه قد يفجر حربا جديدا
على قطاع غزه في حال ذهب لاقتحام المسجد
الاقصى او حاولت تغيير الواقع هناك
بالاضافه الى التصعيد الحاصل اساسا في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله زياد حلبي العربيه
حدود قطاع غزه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينك
الحكومه نتنياهو المقبله في اسرائيل من
اقامه مستوطنات جديده وتعاهد بمعارضه
المستوطنات والضم في الضفه الغربيه واكد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انه واشنطن
ستواصلوا معارضتها الصريحه لاي اعمال تقود
افاق حلت دولتين بما فيها التوسع
الاستيطاني وتغيير الوضع التاريخي الحالي
للاماكن المقدسه والتحريض على العنف
[موسيقى]
نبقى ايضا باجواء كاس العالم وينضم الينا
موفد العربيه الى الدوحه الزميليس بازاري
ليس كيف هي التحضيرات الانطلاق المباراه
بعد قليل وكيف هي اجواء المونديال من هناك
ارى ان هناك علم على وجهك
اي علامه
المباراه
الشخص الذي نشاهد امام الكاميرا
كاس العالم لما لا على كل حال ان شخص
مغسيبه
حضرتك من وين من المغرب
على فرنسا مش على المغرب فرنسا انا هنا
اشجع الاثنين المغرب وفرنسا شو رايك
بالمباراه
قويه الشوط الاول كان ربما لصالح المنتخب
البولوني لكنه الشوط الثاني كان بالمئه
فرنسي همم
لدينا افضل لاعب
وسيقدم المزيد والمزيد والمزيد حتى نعود
للديال الفرنسيه ومعنى الكاس مش الديار
المغربي او الديار المغربيه وستكون هذه
المره مع وليد الرجراجي وابناءه ان شاء
الله ايضا شكرا شكرا لك نعم هذه الاجواء
ليال نحنا هون على فكره في تقاطع طرق اذا
شاهدنا يوجد يعني الكثير من الذين حضروا
بالثوب من المباراه وصلنا قبل دقائق من
قبل دقائق من الان والكثير منهم ياتي الى
هنا للتوجه
من الثمامه المكان الذي تقام فيه المباراه
قبل المباراه كيف هي الاجواء هناك هل بدات
الوفود يعني والحشود بالتوافق وهل هناك
اجواء حماسيه قبل هذه المباراه
المباراه بين انجلترا وسنغال لم نحضرها
للاسف ولم نكن امام الملعب لان كنا مع
الفرنسيين الفرنسا وبولندا قبل قليل ولكن
وصلنا الى هنا على امل ان نشاهد المشجعين
الفرنسيين الذين طبعا ربحوا هذه او فريقهم
والمنتخبهم ربح هذه المباراه وهم ياتون
عاده كما كل الفرق العربيه او العالميه
التي تشارك في كاس العالم هنا في الدوحه
يذهبون مباشره بعد المباراه الى سوق واقف
الى اللؤلؤه الى قطاره الى اماكن اخرى في
الدوحه للاحتفال بذلك وانا يعني نرصد ذلك
شيئا فشيئا فال-ال- همم انتهى الماتش قبل
اقل من ساعه همم من الان وهم ياتون يعني
همم عن طريق الحافلات عن طريق المترو الى
هذه المنطقه كان فريق العربيه سبائهم
فننتظر وصولهم بعد دقائق ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله همم مبروك ليس وشكرا لك على هذه
التغطيه
[موسيقى]
قال قصر باكينغهام انها تاج القديس ادوارد
التاريخي الذي كان محور تتويج الملوك في
انجلترا لاكثر من 350 عاما جرى نقله من
برج لندن لتعديله بحيث يتناسب مع قياس راس
الملك تشارلز الثالث ليتمكن من ارتدائه في
مراسم تتويجه في مايو ايار المقبل
[موسيقى]
تحتفل جزيره سينتها لنا بميلاد جوزيف
السلحفاه العملاقه التي تعتبر اقدم كائن
على قيد الحياه يحتفل بعيد ميلاده 190
ويسكن في منزل حاكم الجزيره الواقعه جنوب
المحيطه الاطلسي
لا اله الا الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد حل شرطه الاخلاق الرئيس الايرانيه
يشير الى امكانيه دراسه مواد بدستور
البلاد
اجتماع كان الهدف بالوضع السياسي الراهن
والتشاور حول كيفيه الوحده الصف الوطني
بين المكونين العسكري والمدني
مع الاكراد الجيش العراقي
على الحدود مع كل من ايران وتركيا
وفي مونديال قطر فرنسا الى الربع النهائي
واسود التيرانكا يتحدون الاسود الثلاثه
بعد لحظات من الاب
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى الزميل
راويه و 360 راويه ماذا لديك اهلا بك
بالاخضر اللون المشترك اليوم
سنتحدث طبعا عن حال شرطه الاخلاق بايران
عن النفط الروسي المعاقب عن فساد قطاع
الادويه في العراق
[موسيقى]